on wednesday president joe biden
announced what could be the biggest
round of student loan forgiveness of his
presidency the new relief forgives up to
20 thousand dollars in student loans for
individuals who qualified for federal
pell grants for low-income first-time
college students
there will also be ten thousand dollars
in relief for all other federal student
loan borrowers both of these offers are
subject to income caps
one hundred twenty five thousand dollars
for individuals and two hundred fifty
thousand dollars for households
14.6 million borrowers had 10 000 or
less in federal student loan debt as of
the end of june and are in line to have
all of their debt forgiven if they fall
below the income cap
this represents roughly a third of all
borrowers the policy will also erase at
least half of student loan debt held by
the twenty point five percent of
borrowers who owe between ten thousand
dollars and twenty thousand dollars in
addition it will take a significant
chunk out of the twenty thousand dollars
to forty thousand dollars owed by
another twenty one point four percent of
borrowers targeting pell grant
recipients is seen as a way to address
concerns that blanket forgiveness could
disproportionately benefit wealthier
americans according to the federal
reserve the top 10 percent of americans
by income holds 17.4 percent of all
student loan debt
despite the 125 000 income cap research
shows the white house plan still
slightly favors higher income americans
analysis of a ten thousand dollar
blanket relief program published tuesday
by the penn wharton budget model found
69.79
of overall debt forgiveness would go to
the top 60 percent of americans by
income the biden administration has
already forgiven about 32 billion
dollars in student loan debt prior to
wednesday through measures targeting
borrowers who were misled by their
colleges and those who qualified for a
previously obscure public service worker
program biden also announced that the
moratorium on federal student loan
repayments will end december 31st 2022
you